this video is sponsored by Squarespace
stick around until the end of the video
to learn more about a deal they're
making available through my channel and
now over to Grant
[Music]
alright guys welcome to this video today
this one is going to be a guide to
jumping rope as a martial artist so how
to get started in jump rope and how to
incorporate it into your workouts so I
often post different clips of me using
the jump rope in my own workouts on my
story and add quite a few requests from
different people of to make a video of
basically how to get started in this and
how to use it so that's what we're going
to be covering today so the first thing
I'm going to do is I'm going to talk
about the benefits of using the jump
rope and what it can do for you in in
training in this and then I'm going to
give you a few basic tutorials later on
for some of the beginner movements in
jump rope so that you can get started
yourself so the reason I like jump rope
so much is it's a very versatile tool
that you can use in lots of different
elements of your training and it's a
skill within itself like I've said in
other videos before martial arts is like
this big overview skill which is made up
of many other little skills and jump
rope is one of those skills and the
reason I like it so much is because you
can see a real tangible progression you
might start out and be very clunky but
as you keep going and keep training you
you can see your own skill progress in
that which is what you don't get in
other activities and there's lots of
different ways you can develop this as
well
now the first one we'll focus on is
obviously it's going to develop your
footwork and Agility so the rhythmic
patterns that we get into in jump rope
that we train towards are very very akin
to the footwork that we use in martial
arts and boxing and it also improves
your coordination as well so as I said
before this is a skill and you're going
to have to practice and when you start
out you're going to be quite clunky but
as you develop those skills that you
develop in the jump rope then feed into
the rest of your practice and that's
obviously a very crucial element in
martial arts training you know when
we're moving around we need to move in
and out of danger zones quickly evade
strikes and things like that but also in
developing our agility and footwork it
basically makes all of the other skills
that we then practice on top of that
don't initially seem related on the
surface better just because you've got a
better command of your body so the more
of this type of stuff you can do and
this is the way I like to work out in
all different activities I do I try to
pick things that are going to feed into
the rest of my skills as well so I'm not
training different things in isolation
another benefit of using the jump rope
is improving your cardiovascular fitness
and because the jump ropes are versatile
like I said you can use it in many
different many different contexts so at
the moment I'm personally using it more
to warm up before I do more skill
specific stuff but I in the past I have
used jump rope just as its own workout
you know you can extend the rounds and
change the intensity and build as you go
it's just got so many different benefits
in that regard that it can be tail used
for so it's the perfect cardio Fitness
for martial arts just because it
resembles martial arts so closely we're
always very light on our feet very
rhythmic moving in and out and doing
different complex movements that improve
our coordination another massive benefit
for combat athletes specifically is
improving your strength and conditioning
so because when we're using the jump
rope we're hopping up and down so much
it really really develops the muscles of
our legs in the right way as well we're
not just doing slow movements like car
phrases the jumping movements are very
very much like when we're moving in and
out of danger zones you know hitting
pads sparring or something like that and
so it perfectly develops the body in
this way and as you know through many of
my other videos all of the strength and
power that we feed into our strikes
comes from the legs so that's why this
is so good for that you will find that
when you start out doing this it's very
tiring for you because your muscle the
muscular endurance just isn't there but
obviously as you develop this you're
going to build that then that's going to
feed directly into your striking prowess
from that point on top of that
coordination it then builds in a sense
of timing and Rhythm because we have to
coordinate our body to move jump with
the rope and use our hands at the same
time and obviously that's essential for
you know timing strikes and things like
that and the reason this happens is
because it develops efficiency in your
movements but this is exactly the same
principle that I always cover in
Striking you know like when I say that
the more efficient the technique is the
less wasted movement there isn't that
technique so naturally it's going to be
faster and hit with more power exactly
the same in jump rope as well so when
you're a little bit clunky and starting
out you're going to be very inefficient
you know you see people that can't time
their hands and their legs together but
as they refine that movement and
practice that that develops and again
that feeds directly into the Striking
afterwards now jump prep also develops
your focus and like mental discipline I
would call it so it's one of those
activities is where because obviously
you're having to coordinate your whole
body you have to focus and concentrate
and I really like those types of
activities where it's almost like you
have no choice but to focus those are
the times when you become the most
present when you're training and that's
when you can slip into that flow very
easily when you're thinking and you in
your head all the time it's very
difficult to get into a flow State when
you perform a physical activity that
takes up a lot of your mental um
bandwidth you could call it it just
makes it way easier to get into that
flow because you're having to coordinate
yourself so when you're doing this
you'll find that as you start out that
it requires a really great degree of
focus and then as you progress it
becomes easier and easier and if you are
able to do that at the beginning of a
session when you're warming up for
instance and then it's way easier to
remain in that flow for the rest of your
training that day and lastly kind of
building on that element of the cardio
Fitness this can be used for weight
management as well with jump rope
because it's a constant activity I find
it so much more interesting than just a
steady state activity where you're just
repeating the same movement all the time
so you can even add something like 15 to
20 minutes of jump rope onto the end of
your regular workout out and it's kind
of like getting those 10 000 steps in a
day I personally haven't got the
patience to do something like that so I
prefer something that's quicker and also
again I get that added benefit of
building the skill and I enjoy the
activity and so it can be used for that
as well
so now we're going to get into the
tutorial section of this video and I'm
going to be using this jump rope this
just very basic jump rope I do have a
much better speed rope but it is more
difficult to use and I think most people
watching this will be using something
like this so I'm going to be teaching
the tutorial sections using this row
this was probably five dollars or
something like that so you can easily
pick one of these up at a local sports
store and get started right away now the
first thing to address that I think many
people Overlook is the length of the of
the Rope now when you get these they're
usually quite a lot longer and then you
have to adjust it this one I use used to
be quite a lot longer and I didn't
understand until I watched some videos
and learned more about the um the
activity that the Rope should actually
be quite shorter and the professionals
use quite a short rope because again
coming back to that efficiency
it's a very short clearance on the head
and you can have your hands very close
to your body you don't have to be wide
like this which makes more of the
advanced skills a lot easier so a thing
to look for with this is basically take
both of your feet
and stand together
on the middle of the Rope like this and
then put the handles together now if you
see here this comes up to about here
I've seen videos before where people say
it should come up to the chin but that's
way too long and even this one now I
could probably get this a little bit
shorter to make it more efficient now
what I'd recommend with this is
shorten your rope in increments so
you're not going way too far because if
you've already done this activity for a
while you'll be quite used to doing it a
certain way and once I adjusted this
rope I found it difficult because I kept
going back to my old patterns so I'd be
I'd have the Rope shorter and I'd need
to be tighter into the body to be more
efficient but over kind of um doing the
rounds of the jump rope my hands would
drift back out again and I'd start
catching the back of my head and my feet
and things so I would shorten it in
increments and work up to getting it to
where like I said I should probably have
this one a bit shorter I should probably
have it about here but then at that
level even though that's just about an
inch or so you have to be really really
efficient at this level because it's
going to change your Technique
so another thing where many people go
wrong when starting this is they're
using their arms way too much like this
when really you just want to move at the
wrists like this okay and that develops
that takes some skill to develop you'll
probably start to move more naturally
like this and be jumping too high so it
should feel quite effortless when you're
doing it so start with the Rope behind
you like this and watch How I just kind
of move at the wrists
very lightly like this and you see how
it doesn't look like I'm really doing
all that much as I hop up and down and
the Rope just kind of passes over very
naturally so it shouldn't feel forced
many people jump way too high and they
end up going like this they're swinging
can you see how it's kind of like really
out of time and it's much more difficult
but it should be quite rhythmic and
effortless you see I'm just keeping the
Rope very controlled and I can still
speak and you know even like turn around
like this as I'm doing it because I have
that control over it okay so work at
getting it very effortless and you do
that by rotating at the wrists and just
hopping very very lightly off the floor
efficiency now I'm going to teach you
the most basic movements that you can do
and then all of the more advanced skills
build on top of that but the first thing
that we're going to do is literally take
it down to the absolute Bare Bones
foundational level and if you're really
struggling some people are so poor at
jump rope that it's almost
um not beneficial for them to even use
the rope at first because they're all
like this and stuff right so if that's
you I would literally just ditch the
Rope for a minute and just practice just
hopping like this and moving your hands
as if you've got the rope and to see how
it feels okay and get used to that
movement can you see how every time my
feet move my hands basically move with
them just like this so yeah as I'm
rotating there like this so start just
absolutely basic and remove the rope and
then get used to that coordinated
movement and how that feels
now the first step that we're going to
learn is just a basic double-footed jump
over the Rope so it's just what we did
without the Rope before and I just want
you to move very slowly so start with
the Rope behind you again just bring it
over like this and hopping over it try
to keep your legs together and be nice
and controlled you see how I'm not going
very quickly
but if you can if you get used to this
you can speed it up a bit because I
actually find it quite a bit easier when
I'm going a little bit quicker to do
this so literally this is the first
thing to do and and if you're not used
to this you're going to feel this in
your carbs after about a minute or so
and this is sufficient to start building
that skill and the strength in the body
okay so literally just hopping over I
only jump about an inch or so off the
floor keeping my hands nice and tight
and then you can build speed in this as
you go
until you're much more used to it so I'd
recommend doing that
now the next step that we're going to do
is we're going to be running over the
ropes so we're going to be using one leg
and then the other as we go over and
some people find this easier because
when you're using two feet it's more
effort and you haven't got any support
in between but when we do this we've
always got one leg down in between so it
provides that stability so nice and
simple again very slow very controlled
just like this
see I'm just running over
nice and controlled
and then build in speed
so can you see how when I build the
speed
my feet and my hands both coordinate
together so the feet slow down and the
Hands slow down and then as I build the
speed so they're both at the same speed
here
then they both speed up together
and both slow down together and so on if
you're finding value in this video so
far guys I'd like to invite you to visit
my Channel at youtube.com Grant
stevensma and subscribe as I make
regular content similar to this and
other related topics
so what we're going to do now is we're
going to combine those first two steps
together so we had the jumping off the
first two feet like this and then we had
the running over and we're going to do
them in beats of four so you're going to
go one two three four one two three four
one two three four okay the way I'd
recommend doing this as well is
in rounds of like one minute with a 30
second break or something like that so
you can build in the speed as you go so
your first one will be very slow like
this
one two three four one two three four
one three four one two three four
four one two
and you do that for like a minute or so
and then you'd have a 30 second break
then you just repeat the same thing
again a little bit quicker I'd do about
five of these until you're sort of at
your maximum speed so the second one
might be like this
and then progressing
in speed as you go I'd recommend this is
a really good Foundation Building drill
so before you try to do any super
Advanced skills or anything just work on
this for like a few weeks and you can do
it every day I mean how long is say five
rounds of a minute with 30 seconds rest
in between like everyone can find the
time to do that if you're dedicated to
doing it and even though I am quite
competent at doing this I'll still start
out really slow because it warms you up
correctly for the the faster rounds
after so two three four two three four
all right
now we're going to move on to a skill
that requires a little bit more
coordination and skill so this could be
something that you can build up to after
doing that first set of steps and this
is often called the boxer hop so this is
the classic step that you see most boxes
do and this is something that I will
always use to come back to is almost
like a resting activity before I do any
more advanced skills and what it is
basically it's going to drop the Rope
again for now to to demonstrate what
this is like
is will help him from one foot to the
other but there's a beat in between
where we extend our leg out okay so
we're gonna go like this it's up out
back out like this and you see how each
time my hands basically rotate through
if I show from exactly from the side
like this
it's a little bit awkward to show you
like that
so I will do it with the Rope now but
that's basically this step and it
requires that coordination so each time
you do the step the hands rotate under
so it's like you stay on one foot for
two beats but the hands go under each
time okay
and that looks a little bit like this so
starting with the Rope behind you again
up and over
see I lift up nice and relaxed nice and
fluid
on each time yeah and you can speed that
up
and this activity is very similar to how
you want to be in a rhythmic motion with
our sparring can you see how like when
I'm moving around or you know moving
around in my training I'm very much like
on my feet like this
as I move and that's very similar to
this step which is why this is so good
for this and why boxes do it a lot as
well and again this is a very good
resting activity so after you've done
some more of your say like
Advanced skills I'll always come back to
doing this okay and then running in here
and then back to this this is always a
good thing to rest in so by training
that it builds basically like the
underlying layer of all the advanced
skills that you can add on on top of
that
what we're going to cover now is just
the side swings I don't know what these
are actually called but I do them in my
training so I'm going to teach you them
now okay all this is is as I'm doing say
the boxer hop that I did in the last one
I just swing to the side like this okay
and when we do that we still hop on the
spot as if we're moving I'm not just
still like this okay because then it
takes more effort to get going again you
see I'm still moving in that rhythm
as I move through yeah and all we're
doing is basically
just swinging the Rope this way and it
crosses over and then recorrects itself
again so those are just something that
you can do in between other movements as
well
I'd recommend building that from the
boxer hop okay so like this
side swing back into it
and just keeping that Rhythm throughout
this is going to teach you to move
correctly okay
foreign
ERS now which are still a further
Advanced skill and this is where just
like the name suggests the Rope passes
under you twice as you jump in mid-air
now the main thing that people get wrong
with this is and Rocky actually does
this Rocky does it wrong so I'm gonna
put that out there right now his Rocky
jumps up with his knees up like this
okay and you don't want to do that you
want to keep your legs quite straight or
you almost want to come into this sort
of slight dish position when you do it
the way these look is just like this
okay I'm doing this boxer hot
and then in a moment I'm just going to
extend both my legs straight and double
under underneath okay
see I went under like that
I don't go like this
that's how rocky does it right you want
to keep your legs
[Music]
nice and straight under and I caught my
foot on the bottom of that one see so
the reason we lift our legs up is to
give a little bit more clearance but it
also creates that nice dish position
that we use in all of our striking
movements as well and I would use these
just every now and then or you can do
multiple double unders okay they do
become quite Tire in there so if you're
doing multiple
just like that right and you can build
that in I like to do them as almost like
a burnout at the end of my rounds so
that's double unders
right so the last one we're going to
cover today is just the crossover and
this one builds upon the running over
the Rope okay so when we do crossovers
we lift one leg like this and then we
fold our hands like this bring the Rope
behind us and then restrain it again
back to its normal position and these
are quite difficult so again I wouldn't
attempt these until you're very very
proficient with the other skills you
need to keep yourself quite narrow on
this so that goes back to that basic
technique again you don't want to be
super wide like this try to be quite
narrow and again that comes to the
length of the Rope
but when you do this you need to be
quite almost not forceful but you need
to give it enough effort to get it
behind you in this cross position and
you might not be Crossing enough either
so make sure you get your hands to where
you see how in this position the Rope
can fully clear my body whereas if I'm
here it's it's going to hit my body so
you need to make sure that you're doing
that again you can do this with without
the Rope first to get used to the
feeling of it now the way these look is
like this so if I'm running over and I
cross it like this
if you are going off on each one
just like that okay it's a little bit
awkward to try and give you a
slow tutorial breakdown of it because it
requires the speed to do it so again I
wouldn't try and do that until you're
very proficient with the other skills
because a lot of this stuff is just you
can have to try it out yourself and
figure out how to do it by making lots
of mistakes
so I hope you enjoyed this video today
guys jump rope is again like I said a
very versatile skill you can use it for
so many different things I like to just
use it at the minute to do some warm-up
rounds and I'll build in speed and I
don't really do one specific skill
during the rounds I'll just do a range
of different things and build up the
speed as I go if you want to see more of
how I actually use this there is a video
that I made before showing my training
that I'll link in the description where
I use the jump prep in the beginning of
the rounds and you can see the speed and
intensity that I use but like any other
skill jump rope is something that
requires a lot of practice so don't be
disheartened if you can't do it straight
away and it's doubly frustrating because
not only are you not able to do it when
you begin but you get the punishment of
being like whipped on the legs or
whipped on the back of the head or
something like that so you've got to
remain patient and focused but it's a
good discipline exercise you know to
like realize you're working towards
something despite not being able to do
it and that's how you build a skill in
something so thank you very much for
watching this one today guys and please
visit and subscribe to my social media
Pages at Grant even to me for more
related content like this and I will see
you in the next video
today's sponsor Squarespace so
Squarespace is a website building
platform that makes it extremely easy
and intuitive to build whatever kind of
website you have in mind for me it was
building the bioneer website and the
biomatrix prior to that that led to the
creation of the bioneer YouTube channel
and changed my life completely allowing
me to turn my passion into a career
Squarespace is the best way to build a
website for beginners all the way
through to professionals that's because
it makes it extremely easy with tools
like it's fluid engine that lets you
just drag and drop elements straight
into your design but at the same time it
has all of the advanced features you
could possibly want to grow your
business to any scale you have members
areas so you can build your own
community and use that to monetize your
site further e-commerce of course for
selling products appointment booking you
can even sell merch you can host videos
and monetize those as well and thanks to
the ability to add third-party plugins
you can expand this even further for
example expand the e-commerce Suite by
adding things like global Shipping and
tracking inventory this is why it's able
to power the websites of some of the
biggest brands on the web
because it's so easy and intuitive to
get started with and you need zero
coding you can just start it in your
room and you never know it might lead to
so yeah I highly recommend building a
website I highly recommend checking out
Squarespace and if you want to learn
more you can go to squarespace.com and
when you're ready to launch head to
squarespace.com forward slash bioneer to
get 10 off of your first domain or
website thanks again to Squarespace for
sponsoring this video thanks to Grand
for making it and thanks to you guys for
watching
bye for now